paul tex lecor fils de la liberté
si le titre de l'exposition qui lui est
consacrée à repentigny
en plus de collaborer avec lui sur scène
et à la télévision
je l'étais roues à partager l'atelier de
l'artiste faisait des fresques où il
entrait cas en quarante cinq personnes
s'étaient mais c'était fabuleux de voir
ce et soudainement il y avait d'un éclat
de rire incroyable je lui disais qu'est
ce qui se passe c'est que les musées aux
écoutes bien vous rêviez voir rien voir
ses personnages prenait forme au fur et
à mesure parfois snobé parce qu'elle
était considérée comme de l'art
populaire
les toiles de tex lecor val athènes
qu'on y jette un deuxième coup d'oeil
c'est ça être peintes c'est d'avoir un
contact direct direct avec l'âme des
gens et c'est un être de luminosité
d'une générosité vous le verrez
d'ailleurs dans chacune de ses doigts
né dans une famille d'artistes et formé
à l'école des beaux-arts tex lecor est
une vedette de la radio et de la
télévision
il a connu le succès comme auteur
compositeur interprète temps qu'il reste
[Musique]
mais la peinture a été l'une de ses plus
grandes passions
il aurait été plus heureux c'était dans
son atelier lui à entrer dans son
atelier et cirrus chevreuse et sommes en
bagarre indépendantiste tex lecor aimé
survolé le québec dans son avion
ça lui a permis d'aller souvent dans la
baie d'ungava qui ai pas cherché à
caricaturer y avait un grand respect
pour les premières nations dont il y
avait plusieurs amis et là il se
fermaient puis écouter
membre des peintres de la nourriture tex
lecor peignait la splendeur et les
couleurs de la belle province et
beaucoup d'histoires à l'intérieur des
toiles de textes si l histoire du québec
il ya l'histoire de la liste son
histoire à lui et à l'histoire de ses
amis mais surtout de son grand
patriotisme
il aimait profondément le québec est il
là il l'a installé dans toutes ses
toiles tex lecor est mort en 2017
mais ces peintures reste et elle célèbre
magnifiquement le prétend québécois tue
chaque année refleurit ici n'est dit
alexandre chartier adieu canada
repentigny
[Musique]